so because you're doing it just like
that right now um you know Sex In The
City the the show has a whole new life
because it's funny because all these
streaming services everybody's like
getting back in there like yes so
they're like watching the whole thing
and now they're getting in just like
that like afterwards but my question is
you know our kids like even like certain
music videos I did my daughter would be
like you are wearing a crop top and I'm
like getting called out by my
seven-year-old and so I'm like I'm
interested like are you scared when they
watch checks in the city at all like you
know when they're older I've had
different thoughts about it at different
times one time Gem and I were on a plane
before Wilson came and she was like
Mommy
the person in front of you that the
their monitor that girl looks like you
and I was like that that is me oh no and
I was like what show are they watching
what's going to happen what are we gonna
it was fine it was the first movie it
wasn't anything bad but she was young
right so it was like a little scary but
now that she's older and now that she's
getting exposed from her friends to all
this stuff even though I'm very
controlling I was thinking I mean she
knows about it she knows the vague topic
we haven't gone into it but I'm thinking
I'm gonna use it as like a teaching tool
you know I want them to feel it's
empowering those for women right I don't
want her to feel embarrassed I don't
want her to feel I want her to talk to
me I'm a single mom it's super important
do what I mean yeah I'm talking right
gotta keep this gotta keep the vanilla
because they'll learn it on the school
bus exactly right exactly exactly that's
what I did too so you know Sex In The
City is kind of a good educational type
thing yeah for later no totally and I
think that it's one of those things
though where I always find it
interesting too because I feel like some
people be like oh I was shy away from
doing I was like wait you weren't shy
doing it it was empowering and it was
cool and I think for the right age it's
like important okay that's right that
book passed around
yep yep
[Music]